you won't vote you're not going to vote
young voters often being considered
politically uninterested
young voters here could make a big
difference you're not going to vote okay
you hear me why do i know that because
i'm just using basic statistics here
youtube tells me that
71 of my audience all of you watching
are between the ages of 18 and 34 years
old okay that's me too
i'm 32 years old so whatever i'm in this
demographic
we can also be represented on a graph
that shows how many of us
show up to the polls every election
back in the 80s that number was around
50 percent half and then by the 90s it
dipped down
really low to like 40 percent
and then it went up a little and then in
2016 the last general election
it was 46 meanwhile the older folks are
way up here in like the 60s and 70s
people over 65 have almost
50 percent more representation in our
democracy
because simply they show up to polls and
they vote
whereas a lot of us stay home but here's
what blows my mind about this as i think
about it this year
i was this guy like i was this guy i was
the person who didn't vote who didn't
really think about this as some
super important thing let's just like
rewind
at me being this guy in 2012. of course
i was on youtube watching all the
celebrities telling me that it's my
civic duty to go out and vote
only one wrong vote and that is no
vote and they would use this weird
phrase like get out and vote it was like
get out
and vote so on november 4th get out and
vote i was like why are we saying get
out all the time
so weird like this what a weird phrase
we don't use that for anything else i
would hear these celebrities and i would
kind of
roll my eyes like yeah i get it we're in
a democracy this is important but
it's not that important and you know
what added to all of this for me in 2012
is that these ads these celebrities they
made it sound so easy
just like take a couple minutes and go
vote like it's actually not that easy
voting in america requires a bit of
research
and a bit of effort not a ton but more
than
what a lot of people make it sound like
and this is all made muddier by the fact
that every state has specific rules i
was moving around a lot of this time i
was in oregon and then i was in utah and
i was in virginia
and every one of these states has
slightly different rules on how to
register when to register
how to actually vote which is why
there's a youtube channel
literally dedicated to how to vote in
every state
it requires a tutorial so yeah voting
requires a little bit
of research and effort and we should be
upfront about that
look at this ranking of 20 democracies
ranked by how much young people show up
to vote
of course up here we have the
scandinavian countries who have a huge
majority of people under 30 who vote
cool we get it scandinavia you figured
out how to run
countries and societies in a very
democratic and
functional way okay let's just why don't
you keep bragging about it scroll down a
little bit
a lot and you get to the united states
way down here
whoa whoa whoa what what's going on here
hold on what is going on switzerland
is even lower 33 switzerland
my switzerland wait but i thought
switzerland was like
the perfect country there's got to be a
good reason for this i mean switzerland
does
have political parties that share power
and so elections aren't really that
important and they have all these
referenda
oh my gosh just admit that it's not
perfect
i'm just not willing to do that okay you
can go back to your computer
i need to take a break and tell you
about today's
sponsor uh for a minute to sort of
refresh
today's sponsor is simply safe which is
kind of a cool thing this box arrived at
my house i opened it up and it was a
bunch of security stuff
all of these things that um i've never
really had before i guess i've always
associated
security system companies with being
sort of like these sleazy salesmen that
show up to your house and make you sign
all these contracts and before you know
it you're like in a five-year commitment
this was like the literal opposite of
that it was a box
that showed up to my house there was no
drama there was no commitment there was
no signing i have a studio
that has a bunch of gear in it and i've
always sort of in the back of my head
wondered like
should i have a security system and
i've thought yes but the problem is it's
always been sort of intimidating for me
to
think about how to even do that simply
safe is a very easy solution
for getting security into your home in a
very non-threatening way what i like
about this
is that it's incredibly accessible it
takes less than an hour to set up you
can put
sensors on whatever doors or windows
you want or think are necessary you can
put up their hd cameras wherever you
want the motion sensors you can just
customize it
you don't need some sales man or
technician to come out
and like soup up your house you can just
do it yourself in
an hour with these really easy to use
tools that's a big selling point for me
no commitments or contracts or anything
it's just really nice to use
technology that helps secure your house
24 7.
once it's set up it has an automated
feature that
calls the police if there's any breach
of the security system these products
have won
awards and i'm not surprised why they're
just really useful so there's a link in
my description
that when you click it helps support
this channel but it also
helps you learn more about simply safe
and how you can get
a security setup for yourself so go
click that link
and go check it out thank you simply
safe okay
let's get back to voting still not very
happy about the switzerland
flex over there from my wife just admit
that it's not perfect
okay so back to voting less than half of
people under 30
don't vote and what does this actually
mean for our society
well it means that older people have way
more representation
to elect other older people who have
different perspectives and priorities
than younger people do tax cuts for rich
people who tend to be older people
check they usually don't want things to
change very much because they've sort of
been doing it the same way for so many
years
check the changing climate yeah they
certainly
care about climate change but like
they're not going to be on the earth for
that much longer so it's like they don't
actually care they don't have skin in
the game with the climate change thing
this is why one election expert said
that if younger people
showed up to the polls in the same
proportions as older people
it would fundamentally transform
american politics but wait
let's go back to 2012 johnny and go
through another thing that was in his
head
because one of the big things is i was
living in utah at the time which is a
deeply red state that was
definitely going to go for mitt romney
and i was an obama person
and so i was thinking my vote doesn't
count
which is actually a very tempting line
of thinking and probably a major reason
why a lot of people don't vote but now
that i have
studied a lot of different governments
and how things work in the world
i realized that that line of thinking is
totally wrong
first off there are loads of people on
that ballot that are not
running for president that are running
for state and local
and county positions that incidentally
have way more effect
on your day-to-day life than the
presidential election
sorry to break it to you but like
presidential election gets all the
limelight and attention
actually probably affects your life a
lot less anyway plus that whole idea of
my vote doesn't count is not how
democracy works
oftentimes democracy feels like a
winner-takes-all situation where whoever
wins
wins and they do whatever they want
because they won that's not totally the
case
even if you vote for a losing candidate
democracy is
a game of pressuring and signaling
leaders
let me explain what i mean leaders of
course take note of
protests and petitions and other forms
of activism
but the thing they really care about the
thing that really pressures them
is the vote because that is the only
thing that can actually lose them their
jobs
even if your candidate loses let's say
you are
a red person voting in a blue state or a
blue person voting in a red state or
whatever the winner of that election
will still note the results of their
opponent
if there's a huge turnout for your
candidate even though they lost
the winner of that election will notice
and they will take note
and they will factor that into their
behavior into their decision making
that is a fact that is how democracy
works because they need to keep an eye
on it because they realize that if there
was a big turnout for their opponent
this time
they need to keep an eye on that for the
next election on the other hand
if you don't vote and you stay home that
candidate who won has zero pressure
they feel zero pressure to behave any
differently because they won so
comfortably
voting isn't just about voting for the
winner it's about
signaling to everyone what the actual
political diversity is
in your city or your county or your
state or your country
your vote actually does matter even when
it feels like it doesn't and this took
me a while to like actually
accept but now i see it very clearly not
only in our democracy but in democracies
around the world
okay i know i sound like i'm sort of
getting a luxury here there are a lot of
really good
rational reasons why young people don't
vote often
we have less flexible jobs so it isn't
easy for us to take
time out to go vote it could cost us a
lot of money to do that often we haven't
made a habit out of it people
that are over 65 have been doing this
for a while they've had time to develop
the habit
and get used to the experience of voting
and honestly that positive association
of going to the polls
voting feeling good about it and then
the next time you're like oh i want to
do that again
young people haven't had the experience
of doing that yet and listen i don't
think this video is going to suddenly
change this line and have it just start
to go up and suddenly we have a 70
turnout for young people though that
would literally like change our entire
country but i do think something is
changing i think us young people are
realizing that
a lot of real serious threats are being
created and exacerbated by
the old folks that have been running
things for a really long time and that
those threats
could actually have huge effects on our
future
and our future job prospects what our
society looks like
and i think we're realizing that yeah
even though
you have to do a little research and
that voting laws are a little different
in every state
that it's worth the effort even if our
candidate loses
to send a signal about what we want and
what we care about
in our democracy
[Music]
bye